salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui je
voulais aborder un sujet qui m'agace dès
qu'on en parle dans la sphère publique
et ce sujet c'est la laïcité aujourd'hui
dès que les journalistes les
intellectuels les politiques ou même les
institutions publiques nous parle de la
laïcité c'est pour nous expliquer que
c'est une pierre angulaire pour le vivre
ensemble entre les communautés
dans toute société or la laïcité à la
française est une spécificité française
une bonne partie des pays dans le monde
n'ont pas cette notion de laïcité y
compris des états modernes qui ont
encore aujourd'hui une religion d'état
et ce sans que bien ces pays et vire
dans la guerre religieuse ou dans
l'anarchie
et ce sujet m'agacent énormément parce
que historiquement la laïcité n'est pas
un élément qui a été pensé pour le vivre
ensemble
ce discours c'est un discours très
récent et qui est une véritable
réécriture de l'histoire et donc c'est
sur cette signification initiale de la
laïcité que je voudrais revenir
aujourd'hui
la laïcité française clairement n'a
jamais été pensé pour être un élément de
vivre ensemble entre communautés mais
c'est un élément qui est en fait
l'aboutissement d'un siècle de
sécularisation de la société française
c'est à dire d'un processus qui consiste
à renvoyer la religion hors de la sphère
politique et publique pour la renvoyer
au privé
alors je vais pas vous faire un cours
d'une heure sur différentes étapes de
de la sécularisation de cette société
mais pour comprendre à quel point
aujourd'hui on a perverti la notion de
laïcité et quel était le combat initiale
de ceux qui ont pensé cette laïcité
est bien pour vous mettre dans l'état
d'esprit de ces gens de l'époque donc
pour comprendre réellement les tenants
et aboutissants de la laïcité
initialement plutôt que de faire un
court je vais je voulais tout d'abord
vous faire une lecture d'un livre
court passage qui est la gloire de mon
père donc roman autobiographique de
marcel pagnol et je vais vous faire
cette lecture avant de continuer ce
sujet puisque le père de marcel pagnol
joseph pagnol était professeur dans
l'enseignement public dans le primaire à
partir des années 1890 il a donc été
formée par la troisième république et
donc dans la gloire de mon père marcel
pagnol ou détail quel est le rapport de
la religion
quel rapport à la religion son père est
l'institution hockey l'éducation
nationale et vous allez voir qu'à
l'époque on est très loin d'une logique
où on veut faire du vivre ensemble et de
la tolérance religieuse
les écoles normales primaire donc les
écoles qui forment formé à l'époque les
maîtres d'école les écoles normales
primaire était à cette époque de
véritables séminaire mais l'étude de la
théologie il était remplacé par des
cours d'anticléricalisme ont laissé
entendre à ces jeunes gens que l'église
n'avait jamais été rien d'autre qu'un
instrument d'oppression et que le but
est la tâche des prêtres c'était de nous
et sous les yeux du peuple lenoir
bandeau de l'ignorance tout en leur
chantant des fables infernal où
paradisiaque la mauvaise foi des curés
était d'ailleurs prouvé par l'usagé du
latin langue mystérieuse qui avait pour
les fidèles ignorant la vertu perfide
des formules magiques la papauté était
dignement représentée par les deux bords
du lez roi n'était pas mieux traités que
les papes s'étirant libidineux ne
s'occupait guerre que de leurs
concubines quand il ne jouait pas au
bilboquet pendant ce temps leurs suppôts
percevaient des impôts écrasant qui
atteignait jusqu'à 10% des revenus de la
nation
c'est à dire que les cours d'histoire et
est élégamment truqués dans le sens de
la vérité républicaine je ne m'en fais
pas grief à la république tous les
manuels d'histoire du monde n'ont jamais
été que des livres et de pros la grande
au service des gouvernements
les normaliens frais évolué et est donc
persuadé que la grande révolution avait
été une époque idyllique l'âge d'or de
générosité et de la fraternité poussé
jusqu'à la tendresse en somme une
explosion de bonté je ne sais pas
comment on avait pu leur exposer sans
attirer l'attention que ceux des anges
laïque après vingt mille assassinats
suivis de vols c'était entre guillotiné
eux mêmes il est vrai d'autre part que
le curé mon village qui était fort
intelligent et d'une charité que rien ne
rebute et considérer la sainte
inquisition comme une sorte de conseil
de famille il disait que si les prélats
avaient brûlé tant de juifs et de
savants ils l'avaient fait les larmes
aux yeux et pour leur assurer une place
au paradis telle est la faiblesse de
notre raison elle ne sert le plus
souvent qu'à justifier nos croyances
également un petit passage un petit peu
plus loin où on parle des professeurs
qui vont être mutés alors par une sorte
de daisy sens la bonne graine était
projeté aux quatre coins du département
pour y lutter contre l'ignorance
glorifier la république et garder le
chapeau sur la tête au passage des
processions après quelques années
d'apostolat laïque dans la neige des
hameaux perdus le jeune instituteur
glissait à mi pente jusqu'au village où
il épouse est au passage l'institutrice
ou la postière
[Musique]
clairement ce que nous décrit marcel
pagnol c'est une république qui ne
cherchent pas le vivre ensemble mais une
république qui cherche à combattre la
religion comme comme il le dit à garder
le chapeau sur la tête au passage des
processions c'est à dire à ne plus
respecter a pu avoir de différence
vis-à-vis de la religion catholique
car la vérité historique est que le 19e
siècle a été un siècle de sécularisation
de notre société c'est à dire de
refoulement du religieux du politique et
la sphère publique dans la sphère privée
et que ça s'est accompagnée par un
combat contre la religion dominante qui
était religion d'état qui est le
catholicisme
la laïcité est l'aboutissement de ce
siècle de combat de la république
radical et socialiste
pour refouler la religion dans le privé
est clairement au delà même de refouler
dans la sphère privée on le sent avec ce
que ce que dit marcel pagnol dans
l'esprit des professeurs de la
république le but ultime était de leur
expliquer que la religion est là était
une abomination qui ne cherchaient qu'à
embrigader les esprits faibles
clairement à la fin du 19e siècle et au
début du 20e siècle la république n'est
pas une république vivre ensemble liste
de république tolérante mais une
république qui a sa propre vision
des choses sur la question de la
transcendance et qui veut créer des
citoyens qu'ils soient athées ou un
minimum agnostique
donc la fable selon laquelle la laïcité
cherche à permettre à chacun de pouvoir
vivre sa religion tranquillement est une
reconstitution a posteriori quand la loi
de 1905 dit dans son article 1er la
république garantit la liberté de
conscience il faut le comprendre dans
son contexte historique on sort d'une
époque où catholicisme était religion
d'état où il était monopolistique
et cette garantie de la liberté de
conscience c'est pour dire vous église
catholique vous n'aurez plus le monopole
des âmes ça ne veut pas dire chacun peut
vivre sa religion ça veut dire on vous
retire ce monopole de la conduite des
armes et on va faire en sorte que votre
croyance soient refoulés et à un moment
disparaissent
et cette logique de laïcité qui est un
aboutissement d'un processus de
sécularisation et qui doit être poussée
au maximum elle a été présente en france
jusqu'à très récemment
par exemple dans le programme
présidentiel de mitterrand en 1981 parmi
les 110 propositions vous aviez la
proposition qui consistait à créer un
grand service public de l'éducation
nationale unifiée ce qui voulait dire en
fin de compte supprimer les
l'enseignement privé confessionnel et
après que mitterrand et gagner il y a eu
une loi qui a été élaboré dans ce sens
la loi savary en 1984 mais devant le la
mobilisation importante de l'église
catholique et de tout l'enseignement
privé confessionnel des parents d'élèves
et c est bien cette loi est tombé aux
oubliettes mais clairement jusque au
moins dans les années 80 la gauche
estimaient que la religion était quelque
chose qui devait être combattu et qu'il
fallait supprimer ce qui est aujourd'hui
encore l'enseignement confessionnel
et la laïcité comme étant un élément de
vivre ensemble entre les différentes
religions c'est un élément de langage
qui est extrêmement récent et c'est
logique puisque
très longtemps on a eu assez peu de
mouvements d'un point de vue culturel la
france était relativement homogène on
avait 1 % de personnes de confession
juive vous aviez quelques pourcents de
protestants concentré dans quelques
régions mais globalement la population
française de vieille souche
et bien été une forme de communauté qui
était au catholicisme puits qui a été
lié à la morale républicaine et qui a
été en grande partie est bien
sécularisée donc la question du vivre
ensemble se posait pas puisque la très
grande majorité en fait était homogène
et donc petit à petit la gauche à partir
du début des années 2000
a modifié son discours sur cette laïcité
enfin du moins la gauche qui a refusé la
loi de 1905 et puis par imprégnation
comme la gauche est très présente dans
les institutions et république eh bien
les institutions publiques et en
particulier l'éducation nationale ont
fini par adopter ce discours
historiquement négationnistes et j'ai
envie de dire de laïcité vivre ensemble
east
et personnellement je trouve que cette
réinterprétation de la laïcité est
extrêmement dégueulasse parce qu'elle
crée deux catégories de citoyens et crée
des citoyens d'abord de vieille souche
française ceux qui ont subi entre
guillemets la république française qui a
acquis la culture est un qui a chassé la
religion du coeur
de cette population qui aujourd'hui
largement déchristianisée et de l'autre
côté vous avez des populations arrivé
récemment à partir notamment des années
90 qui sont de cultures non européennes
qui ont d'autres croyances et aux
populations à qui on dit voilà soyez
citoyens donc comme les français de
souche mais vous pouvez garder votre
culture et votre culture d'origine et en
plus une richesse et quelque part
aujourd'hui si on voulait être vraiment
dans la tradition dans la lignée de la
loi de 1905 on devrait et bien
sécularisée ces populations qu'on
accueille au lieu de valoriser leur
culture d'origine c'est à dire qu'il
faudra leur faire subir le même
processus que celui qui a subi la
population de vieille souche française
on devrait chasser la religion de leur
coeur s'il le faut en adoptant des lois
spécifiques alors certains diront loi
islamophobe mais tout le 19e et 20e
siècles ont été
christianophobes entre guillemets de la
part de la république française et ce ne
serait donc que que justice de créer des
citoyens qui sont uniquement
culturellement des citoyens à partir de
ces populations d'origine étrangère et
d'arrêter de valoriser leur culture
alors que leurs équivalents de souche
française on l'a on l'a dénigrée et on
l'a totalement aujourd'hui chasse et de
l'esprit de la plupart d'entre nous
bref j'espère que ce petit rappel
historique ces remarques vous auront
intéressés si c'est le cas et bien
n'hésitez pas
à partager cette vidéo est sûre ça je
vous dis à la prochaine